- All right, there's always
something on social media
that can bring your day a little extra joy
and I am always here to share the best,
this is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Going under the knife can
be terrifying for anyone
but especially children,
it's like a whole world of unknowns.
So for three decades of pediatric surgeon
in Akron, Ohio has been
helping children get through
the fear and anxiety of the experience
all through the wonder of art.
Dr. Bob Parry, hand draws
colorful characters and pictures
and turns them into bandages
to brighten the kids' spirits,
when they awake from surgery.
We have Dr. Parry on the
line right now watching
on WKYC 3 at 11:00 AM.
Dr. Parry,
hello.
(audience applauding)
- Hey Kelly, how are you?
- I am so much better
now that you're here,
so how did you come up with this idea?
- Well, I have to tell you
it wasn't my idea originally
where I was training
in the early nineties, but
that's the Naval Hospital,
one of my mentors in pediatric surgery,
he used to cut out sharks for
boys and the hearts for girls.
The kids just loved it,
you could see they really enjoyed it
and as I went on to my
practice without ado,
you know, through fellowship,
I was actually out in Los Angeles there
and kept going, did
more and more drawings,
and it just kinda took off from there.
I was thinking the other
day, the past 30 years,
probably 10,000 of these
bandages, I've done over time,
basically every kid I've operated on.
- That is so cool,
well you say this isn't
just about helping kids
after surgery but before as well, right?
- Yeah, actually, you know, honestly,
before is even better,
we get kids sometimes
that have heard about it
and they'll come in, they have ideas of,
"I want this on my bandage."
Other times they wanna really any idea,
then the moms and dads
get excited and they go,
"Oh, what about your dog?"
"Your favorite cartoon
character you love."
And it kinda distracts them completely
from the thought of surgery,
everybody, the parents, the child,
you know, the technical side
of the surgery is a little,
you know, it's obviously
frightening in that time
before you go to the operating room,
they're all quite nervous
and suddenly this is
just a huge distraction,
they all get excited and
honestly, even when they wake up,
you know, they're trying
to look at their bandage.
"Well, what did I get?"
"What happened?"
And it makes it a really nice transition,
and for me, honestly, it's rewarding
'cause the technical side of surgery,
is just hard for anyone
to really understand.
And this gives me the ability to give
a little, you know,
personal piece of myself
that they can relate to a
little compassionately humanity
that's less than the
cold element of surgery
and it's just fun.
- Well, I mean, honestly,
I was gonna bring that up
but it's an amazing thing that
you're able to heal people
and help people in the way
that you do as a doctor,
but it's an even cooler thing
that you take that extra step
in being so compassionate
in a time that's so
frightening for the kids,
their families, everybody.
So thank you so much, all right.
I'm liking your posts now, Dr.
Parry and that's not all man.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
the go to pen at the Kelly Clarkson Show
wants to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you, man.
So they're gonna be using
their G-2 gelling pen
to write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
(audience cheering)
Yeah, all right,
well thank you so much.
- Thank you so much,
that's wonderful.